good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday I'm really
looking forward to the weekend weekend
cause I'm podcasting at you live from
Nashville hey Jax how you doing darn
good how does it feel to be in Music
City
oh I'm ready I've got the music in me
like I'm feeling the power of Nashville
coursing through my veins
for real
no I haven't left the hotel room I got
here last night um a podcasting like I
haven't left my hotel but I could feel
the energy outside it's electric it's
also a big weekend in Nashville last
night the city was a buzz I couldn't
even get to the hotel Janet Jackson was
performing at Bridgestone Arena there
are two College graduations this weekend
Vanderbilt and Belmont I think it's
called so it's just the city it's a
blaze wow congrats to the graduates
congratulations congrats
congrats congrats to the grads
congratulatory congratulations to the
grads if you're a graduate and you're
listening to this episode congrats and
thanks for listening and being a toaster
um
at your you know ripe young age it means
a lot to us and most importantly
congrats yeah and all you've achieved
um we've got a great Audio Only episode
for you guys so our YouTube listeners
hope you can catch us on the ones and
the twos uh wherever you get your
podcast Jax is in New York I'm in
Nashville getting ready for the eras
tour and it's very exciting it's very
exciting any updates on the weekend
plans or the hours tour since you were
on the podcast yesterday
no no nothing's changing
nothing's changing I did change hotel
rooms you know whenever we get to a um
Hotel Ben has a problem with the hotel
room and it's like he's so particular
that I just ignore him but he was 100
right we got put in this dungeon like
literally there were no windows in this
room I actually felt claustrophobic and
that's not even like a condition I
suffer from so there was a change in
rooms last night but other than that the
plans remain the same okay great I'm so
excited to podcast with you but then to
end the podcast so that you can embark
on your nashvillian adventure
um you know I love the Tennessee crew
I'm a Tennessean at my heart and my core
yeah sure
no I really am have you been to any
other parts of Tennessee
yes [__] I know you're trying to catch
me in something no no no I'm just asking
you
I've been to Memphis I have never been
to Memphis well I can't even sing that
song wholeheartedly I've never been to
Memphis so I could sing it
it's stunning truly lots of culture and
I've also been to Franklin which is like
outside of Nashville but it counts Okay
cool so yeah I've been to a few places
that's so awesome isn't it just dandy
do you guys know that Theo's Theo's
birth name the name that he was given at
his breeder was actually Dandy oh geez
no because we were doing the breath when
you got Theo and it was a big topic of
discussion and I wanted you to call him
by his birth name Dandy Hansen and dandy
Hanson and by the way like Dandy first
of all it doesn't roll off the tongue in
anything wrong way you're so wrong and
two like let's call a spade a spade
Dandy is a girl's name like Dandy would
have been an amazing name and you were
wrong for that
I I stand by my decision another Claudia
life fun fact is that Theo actually had
a name change early in his life his Theo
was not his original name and his
original name was Dandy but then his
second name that Claudia named him when
she first got him was
mufi
m-o-o-f-y and it was like a really cute
pet named me and Ben called each other
at the time we still kind of do and we
were like oh my God how cute like if we
actually take this pet name and give it
to a pet and on day one we knew
immediately it was going to be so
confusing like Ben was talking to Theo
movie at the time and I was in the other
room being like yeah are you calling me
it was moronic and it wasn't our best
idea and I'm glad we had the foresight
like not to you know sometimes you have
a bad idea but you just gotta stick with
it because you're stubborn I'm so glad I
was mature enough to realize like you
know maybe this wasn't my best call yeah
so then he rebranded again
he did to Gar just Theo
and it's been a joy ever since honestly
I believe that I'm looking at my own
streisands right here he's been just
like extra Angelic and
we're just having a moment you know when
you go through like waves of just like
core bonding period connection
connection we are extremely connected
these days
I'm thrilled for you I'm thrilled for
streis and I'm thrilled for the
community yeah I'm thrilled for you and
you know what I think we should get into
the episode because you need to embark
on your weekend I know you have big
plans you're like going over to
Shannon's with the girls spray tans
actually do I look tan Shannon sprayed
me and I'm Vlogging this whole thing for
patreon and all the girls who like we
all traveled separately we're staying in
different places we're like a group of
15. they're vlogging too and being
really supportive of the patreon so you
will see you know what's going on me and
Ben are at the hotel with Lauren
Elizabeth because we're just like you
know boring like that mature
Margot and her friends are staying at
Shannon's and then the rest of the crew
got this big Airbnb that's where I'm
gonna go afterwards because I want to
see it apparently it's really nice and
there's like a rooftop Deck with the TV
um so that's where I'm gonna head after
this where was I going with this story
about our patreon
no no well always patreon.com toast but
I got my spray tan last night Shannon
has a full-blown machine and when I tell
you I think it's just as good as any
like professional Sprite she was legit
like doing the hand motions like
like really going at it she's like
spread your thumbs turn to the side
ninja like she was really killing it
amazing
yeah you do look good in tan
thank you
good and tan
when I'm good and ready I'm good and tan
okay should we dive in yeah let's dive
in we actually have really
um real stories for a Friday and for
that I am grateful
me too there's a story I'm excited to
talk about like an influencer drama
thing um that's going on on Tick Tock
and of course we're coming in with a hot
take that No One's Gonna agree with
can't wait for it so now without further
Ado here are the fast five stories that
you need to know
is it you or you
you
okay cool yeah well you need to know
that today's episode is brought to you
by Urban stems the most fabulous flower
delivery service they deliver modern
bouquets and stylish plants next day
Nationwide so for all of our forgetful
Queens who are like always forgetting
people's birthdays anniversaries you
know Mother's Day is coming up Urban
stems has got your back end with
Mother's Day coming up their Mother's
Day collection is curated with love and
adoration in mind every bouquet is
designed in-house and it is super on
Trend all of their deliveries include a
personalized note that is sent to your
recipient thoughtfully designed
packaging and 100 happiness guarantee so
I've been using Urban stems because I'm
constantly sending people stuff I'm like
so generous like that and I only know
about Urban stems because somebody who I
work with whenever they would send me
flowers was always sending me Urban
stems that one day I literally wrote it
down I'm like Urban stems and I've been
using them ever since their delivery is
on point their packaging is super super
cute and the the flower designs are
really beautiful
so um you can schedule your flower
delivery in advance to show how much you
love them don't wait to the last minute
and settle for the disappointing flowers
from the grocery store you can shop by
color price range even flower type and
you can take your pick from a variety of
bouquets plants gifts and floral
subscription options that are all
available at urbanstems.com with
Mother's Day coming up on Sunday May
14th don't forget you can visit
urbanstems.com toast to see some of
their top picks just be sure to order in
time by using Code toast for 15 off your
purchase again Mother's Day is upon us
do not forget go to urbanstems.com
toast get our most beautiful bouquets
and order in time using Code toast for
15 off your purchase that's code toast
for 15 off your purchase today's episode
is also brought to you by the perfect
bar the original refrigerated protein
bar that you know and love for those of
you that live under a rock or who rudely
skip through our ads here are the fast
five things that you need to know about
the perfect bar they're made with
freshly ground nut butter or organic
honey and 20 organic superfoods they
have 17 grams of proteins and they come
in 10 delicious flavors plus they also
come in little snack size bars that are
perfect for a busy toaster on the go
three they're made with only whole food
ingredients they contain no artificial
preservatives and the perfect bar is
stored in the fridge four they have the
most sickening cookie dough texture
perfect bar is unlike any other protein
bar out there and fifth if you aren't
already convinced they're also non-GMO
project verified they're gluten-free
they're soy free they're low GI and
they're kosher so perfect bar knows that
it'll be Love At First Bite so for a
limited time they're offering you a
chance to try the refrigerated protein
bars for free love that these are stored
in the fridge they're so fresh they're
so good and a lot of them have delicious
chocolate in them like dark chocolate
the ones that I like do when you put
them in the fridge they become this like
hard crunchy shell and then the inside
is like that cookie dough texture we
were saying and it's really a perfect it
is a titillating experience for your
taste buds a sensational experience so
if you want to get a free perfect bar
sign up for email texts upload a picture
of your receipt from your local grocery
store and they will reimburse you for
the cost of one bar it'll go directly
into your venmo or PayPal account so
again all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com
toast to get that free perfect bar today
that's perfect snacks.com
t-o-a-s-t to get that free perfect bar
today happy snacking
thank you Claudia you're welcome Jackie
our first story Little legal news Ed
Sheeran has been found not liable in
copyright lawsuit he says he feels the
truth Was Heard and believed so a jury
has found Ed Sheeran not liable in a
lawsuit filed against him for alleged
copyright infringement over his 2014
single thinking out loud uh he was
accused of lifting direct elements of
the Marvin Gaye classic song Let's get
it on for this Grammy Wing winning
single Thinking Out Loud the unanimous
verdict was reached after about a
three-hour deliberation by seven jurors
in a New York City courtroom on Thursday
Ed said quote I feel like the truth Was
Heard and the truth was believed it's
nice that we can both move on with our
lives now it's sad that it had to come
to this he was like really spinning out
rattled by this whole situation he had
said earlier this week like if the case
didn't go his way he was like quitting
music because like this is his artist
he's lost all Faith he lost all faith in
the process as he also said that he
missed his grandmother's funeral I think
because in New York for the trials like
Ed Sheeran is pissed and while the trial
was happening I wasn't keeping up with
it and I don't know and how thinking out
loud is similar to Let's get it on but I
assume they had like a good case if they
were pursuing it but apparently like the
estate of Marvin Gaye Just Like tries to
pursue everyone for everything
yeah apparently it's just like a thirsty
estate you know going after everyone and
how they were similar is that like
basically most popular songs consist of
like a uh four chords like repeated and
there are only so many chords out there
so it was like the same four chords but
I see these videos on Tick Tock all the
time it's like did you know that this
song and this song have the same four
chords and like oh if you listen to it
yeah there are only so many ways to like
on a guitar or piano like create a song
at its core it's not that crazy it's not
that uncommon and it really was like a
not it really wasn't clearly because the
jury agreed there wasn't that much
evidence that it was a copycat like
there are certain coincidences
coincidences and similarities in the
songwriting and music making process and
this was just one of them and like Ed
Sheeran was [__] pissed like not me
and never seeing him angry before like
he was like I will quit yeah yeah let's
like be okay with parallel thinking one
and two I actually pride myself as
Talent of mine is being able to hear a
song and tell you like a similar song or
like something that has like a similar
element and the fact that I didn't catch
this I just feel like they should have
had me on the witness stand because this
was not a match
no Ben does that too he'll be listening
to a song he'll be like wait he's like
literally like a mathematician like wait
one second and then he'll literally like
look through his Spotify for the song
he's looking for and you know what he
does make a really good call like some
sometimes these songs sound so familiar
yeah no I have a few that come to mind
but one that's just like so underrated
is um the beginning of honky tonk
Highway and Rockstar by Hannah Montana
and another one I don't know who
maroon by Taylor Swift and
100 by Claudia ashrae yeah that one
honestly you have a case no I know yeah
I think that a lot about songs but
that's just like we're all like all
these people are just writing
confidently in the same fired
yeah like there are only so many
instruments so many chords so many words
like it's not that crazy I don't hear
the similarities at all and it just
seems so obvious like okay it's clear
that like the estate of Marvin Gaye is
like on this like war path like they're
suing people left and right and to go
after like Ed Sheeran for thinking out
loud it's just like the biggest song
ever like it's just so obvious
yeah especially like it's embarrassing
that they didn't have a case and now
whatever case they bring forward next
like I'm not going to take it seriously
because also like typically you would
take something like this seriously
people don't go to court and sue right
their artistic property especially
posthumously without well that's like
this makes me think of Tom Petty estate
suing Sam Smith and winning for Stay
With Me
and what was Tom Petty's song
um I don't remember but they won because
they're really the songs were exactly
the same damn right so you would think
like there's a case but there's no case
here and I feel like this chips away at
people who do have a real claim
yeah like it also chips away at the
Integrity of all future lawsuits coming
from the gay estate 100 100 so I'm glad
I saw this through I'm sorry he missed
his grandma's funeral I'm glad it went
his way and that he'll continue to make
math based records
yeah his album subtract is coming out
soon it's really important for the math
community that Ed Sheeran not quit the
industry
yeah you know I was watching young
Sheldon last night my absolute favorite
show about the boy Genius Sheldon Lee
Cooper and he if only young Sheldon were
alive to see
what
Ed Sheeran has done he would have loved
Ed Sheeran you think a hundred percent
math based music that he could get down
to 100 do you know who loves young
Sheldon
who Dana
I have to talk to her about it she would
she is young Sheldon
literally young Sheldon needs a
girlfriend in the show called Dana a
young dude I got to the episode last
night where like he like falls in love
with this girl
um and she's like he's in high school
but he's nine years old and this girl's
like 17. and she wants to take him to
like an IMAX movie in Houston which is
like a two-hour drive away so Sheldon's
mom's like I need to meet this girl and
she meets the girl and the girl is
lovely and the girl says don't worry Mrs
Cooper I've babysat before and Sheldon
is crushed because he didn't realize
this girl was like babysitting he really
felt like this girl loved him
I'm depressed thank you for that it
reminds me of that story of that
nine-year-old who's going to college
Jackie every time I watch young children
I think about that story that we
reported on the toast a few weeks well
months ago and I just hope I mean the
grads are grading right now so he
probably doesn't start until the fall
and I'm just thinking of him like every
once in a while I'm thinking of him and
I hope that college is everything that
he deserves it to be and everything he
imagined it would be yeah even at age
nine because I'm sure it's hard to have
a proper college experience at age nine
right
right thinking of him today and always
yes are you ready for our next story yes
I know you're not gonna care but I love
to close the loop on a Bebe name and
Chloe and Tristan's baby boy's name has
finally been revealed according to the
U.S sun which is so [__] random but
the couple has named their baby boy who
was born last summer Tatum Robert
by the way I do care I saw this and I
was shocked at how normal it was like
just like a name I had heard before not
a name that was made up yeah I agree she
said she was going to do a t name there
are only so many T names out there I
think Tatum is a really beautiful name
then you add the Robert which is very
significant to Chloe and I think it's
beautiful
I like it a lot actually it like it's so
kind of um like Instagram blogger mommy
blogger like it's so not Kardashian yeah
Tatum Robert Thompson that's a nice name
it's very it has like a a kingly sort of
stature to it it's very
like respectable brother of Truesdale
Thompson
right true and Tatum is so cute she's
obviously sticking with the Tea theme
which like I just hate because the t is
obviously for Tristan or Thompson like
because she likes how her first name and
her last name correspond so her kids are
Thompson's so they're teas
that's actually a really good call so oh
and you know it was nice that like even
when everyone was calling him Tristan
third trimester Thompson that still was
all tease it was an alliteration so at
least they could sleep easy right
knowing that while he was the most hated
man in America at least they were
staying on bread do you know what I
watched recently like last week it was
just on TV and I was just watching cable
Chloe and Lamar's wedding no the
episodes of Kardashians wear Tristan
smooched Jordan Woods
all those clips always come up on my
Tick Tock it was really crazy to watch
back because at the time it was the
biggest deal
and even watching it again like it was
just
the craziest thing
no and by the way something we didn't
even talk about because I feel like I
don't remember when it happened but
recently it was announced red table talk
is canceled because I talked about it
yeah uh oh Facebook watch is kaput yeah
but Olivia and I both concluded that we
think that it will get picked up by a
network because it's they're all for all
those shows are kind of for sale now
or like a YouTube Originals because it
really was good as like a web show yeah
yeah I think it won't be the last time
we see the table that is read
no and when we think about like all the
iconic moments like of course Jordan
Woods Olivia Jade like they really were
like out there doing the most on red
table talk yeah
yeah but it was just so absolutely crazy
time
it was a crazy time that Jordan thing
like I literally remember where we were
we were in Utah on family vacation and
you and I did like an emergency podcast
it was we couldn't believe it it was the
scanned of all level
yeah yeah
yeah but not as crazy as Scandal because
like an affair versus a kiss are very
different
no and honestly I can't think of
anything that's happened in the last 10
years that is as crazy as can of all
like I know that sounds crazy but it is
by far the most mind-blowing thing
that's ever happened to me like for real
and it's not even happening to me it's
not even happening to me Jax I
understand well speaking of scandival
actually gonna swap the stories around
because our next story is a little Bravo
Vanderpump news okay Lisa Vanderpump is
closing her beloved La restaurant pump
for good Lisa Vanderpump's pump
Restaurant and Lounge in West Hollywood
is closing its doors after 10 years of
business on July 5th she told e-news
it's with heavy hearts that we announced
at the lease at pump restaurant is
expiring she explained that they had
previously signed a 10-year lease but
when it came time to renew the price had
increased too significantly and it
wasn't something that they were ready to
commit to after successively running 37
plus establishments for many years this
type of rent is untenable she didn't
specify how much the rent would increase
but sources told TMZ that will cost a
million dollars a year to lease the
space however the landlord for pump
denied both the source and Vanderpump's
claims and said to page six that it's
not accurate quote we did not raise the
REM and in fact have been nothing but
supportive as they tried to catch up on
lease obligations including for giving
some rent during coven
all right well I don't I feel weird
about a Latin Lord who talks to page six
honestly like that's crazy no but like
if the landlord didn't say anything we'd
be like you know these landlords are
like they're just raising rents rents
are crazy so I I do think like it's
germane to the story that he say we
didn't raise the rent but how do you not
raise the rent with like that's what I'm
saying after 10 years and with inflation
like all real estate rents are going up
they have prime location in West
Hollywood like raising the rent is
it's not unfathomable that he would
raise the rent like especially after 10
years and
given all the economic circumstances uh
honestly her first statement made a ton
of sense to me like if the rent went up
so much I'm sure not all of her
restaurants are as popular as they used
to be like I wouldn't even consider this
a failure I think like the restaurant
business is so hard and having a popular
establishment in West Hollywood for 10
years is actually a huge accomplishment
um but now that knowing that the rent
actually wasn't increased which also
sounds like a lie to me because you're
right even in the best of Economic Times
after 10 years rent changes that's just
how like the market works even if it
goes up by like a thousand dollars like
rents change right right and I do think
that pump is a success they had a
10-year run and now some of her other
restaurants are bigger like TomTom sirs
really big I feel like there is not
really a place for pump right now like
it's just not
as
necessary as it once was
you know what's crazy is like we were
watching the show when pump was being
built and so that was 10 years ago like
I could vomit like that's insane that is
insane but it's full circle also with
Villa Blanca closed down
um but she has Vanderpump cocktail
Garden at Caesar's Palace in Vegas and
that is literally when you get to Vegas
level like you're like so rich like I
think she's fine yeah no I think she has
two places in Vegas no I'm not worried
about her and I think like sometimes
things come to an end and it's not like
they were evicted it was like the lease
we had to reassess it and it just
doesn't make Financial sense like okay
great yeah moving on
yeah and I'm also not in my like hating
Vanderpump era like I was many years ago
like everything she did I was like oh my
God like I I've come to actually
she's endearing herself to me quite a
bit so I'm okay with this rest in peace
rip pump rip Yeah the more I think about
it the more it makes sense pump is kind
of like doesn't have a place in the
Vanderpump ecosystem right now it just
doesn't like sometimes literally right
down the street every event that they do
they do it at Tom Tom and Sir is still
the Hub like great trim the fat trim the
fat
is Lisa at all involved in something
about her she's like helping them with
the lease and she's like going to the
sandwich and they said they're going to
take on investors like I'm sure she's
going to be a part of it I don't think
she I mean she said like over and over
again she's not investing I think she
has taken on this advisor role one
because she likes Katie and Ariana but
two it's her role in the show
yeah
but like it would like it's such a
smaller operation it's not a bar so I
don't need like a liquor license it's
not gonna be much cheaper she should
just invest a little especially now that
like everyone's so team Ariana and Katie
like they're gonna they're gonna destroy
the fans destroy shorts and sandies and
make this the number one sandwich shop
in West Hollywood yeah no it would be a
good investment but as of right now
she's not slated to invest
right her role though is just like a
little weird
it makes sense in the context of the
show and all she did was like connect
them with her realtor it's not like she
was out there no she but like she knew
that they got had gotten approved for
the lease before they did yeah but like
that's weird Lisa show Ting yes Lisa
showdings Lisa showdings anyways goodbye
to pump
rip pump
now before we dive into the next story
let me let you know that the remainder
of today's show is brought to you by
Lululemon specifically the Lululemon
align collection so everyone's always
saying turdy turdy your flare pants you
look so snatched where are they from
they are from Lululemon I'm obsessed
with these pants they're from the Align
collection and the Align collection has
like amazing products and then like I
also love the biker shorts but these
flare pants look really
um really speak to like a different part
of my soul I wear them everywhere and
they're so versatile like not me wearing
them to the airport and then also like
to a full-on business meeting you could
dress them up dress them down boots
sneakers whatever it is and the Align
collection is everything of the sort so
all of their
um items in the Align collection have
the best flexibility so it's made with
this four-way stretch that means you can
bend stretch move literally any way you
want to without restrictions or
distractions and without like that band
digging into your stomach to the point
where you're like nauseous enough to
pull your pants down in the back of an
Uber if you've been there you know
they're also really comfortable they're
made with nulu fabric for the softest
comfiest texture that your legs have
ever felt it's true it's like that
Lululemon thing everything they have is
just like so soft and like thin but also
coverage and warm it's not sheer
um and the fit is fabulous it shapes
perfectly to your body for a flattering
look that is uniquely you they're also
weightless it feels like you're wearing
nothing and nothing else
so I love again the pants that I'm
talking about are the high rise mini
flare pant from the Align collection but
they have great great products in the
Align collection besides that like those
biker shorts running shorts really great
stuff so get into the Lululemon align
collection it's available now at
lululemon.com of course that's l u l u
lemon.com and that's the Lululemon align
collection thank you Claudia
you're welcome Jackie our next story SNL
revealed the final Two Hosts that were
booked before the writer strike strike
shut down they had booked Kieran Culkin
and Jennifer Coolidge as the final
season 48 hosts and as we talked about
yesterday Pete Davidson but SNL fans
will have to wait a bit longer for the
return of new episodes due to the
ongoing Writers Guild of America union
strike people has confirmed the NBC
series will not produce any more new
episodes this season including Kieran
Culkin's slated return and Jennifer
coolidge's big debut that would have
been her first time hosting and honestly
that's really tough for everyone those
are both I watched Kiernan's uh last
year I feel like he's like on this thing
now where like whenever succession is on
he like gets booked on SNL his last one
was so good
um that sucks like that just [__]
sucks for us the by the way this wga
strike is like it's everywhere
yeah it's everywhere we were sending
each other's stuff back and forth
yesterday like there's a lot of new
there's a ton of news surrounding it a
lot of people are dropping out or not
participating in events in support of
the writer's strike the writer strike
signs are going viral because they're
like pretty shady funny funny Shady yeah
uh is there's just a lot
yeah there is a lot I do have a question
because I feel like I think a lot of
like major celebrities like throwing
their weight behind the wgas like
actually helpful like I saw Cynthia
Nixon was down there Chessie from Parent
Trap was down there like throwing their
support a lot of people are pulling out
like John Mulaney pulled out of this
event because he's like a writer to his
core then I also saw like lala Kent
pulling out of like appearances and I
don't understand how that helps the
writers I thought the same thing lalakan
is uh like not going to an award show
and I was like how does that help the
writers I don't understand like maybe it
does like maybe it does but I don't
understand how so just like drop it in
the car explain it to me yeah explain to
me how it helps the writers because I'm
hella confused
um but also like if I was a celebrity
and there was like an event I really
didn't want to do or like didn't want to
go or like a job I didn't want to take
I'd be like you know what I support the
writers and I do support the writers so
I wouldn't even be lying but you'll
notice no one skipped the Met Gala in
support of the writers
well the Michaela is actually not like a
Hollywood like they're protesting the
networks I also misspoke yesterday when
I said it was just NBC it's all of them
it's the streamers it's everything
um and I don't think that in the mecca
really has anything to do with like
networks and cable and streamers
no no it doesn't but like a lot of some
of these events don't have much to do
with like the rights
that's true that's true it feels just
like picky and choosy you know it used
to like how you used to be like oh I
can't come I have covid or oh I was
exposed yeah by the way did you watch
Adam and a secret interview I was
telling you about yesterday I saw one
clip how [__] funny was it really
funny I love her passion
you know what it was reminding me of a
little bit man you know it was reminding
of Vanessa Hudgens covet video you know
what was reminding me of terrible
but inevitable no it was reminding me of
because like it's just the way she's
talking is so weird it's also the stuff
coming out of her mouth but she's like
kind of drunk like dude like the [__]
like give the writers what they bond
like and it was like that video when
like this secret company or like kind of
like a hype Beast I forget like YouTube
channel did a video with Bella Hadid in
a sneaker store and she's like if my
dude rolling up in these kicks he's
fresh man everyone [__] roaster like
what are you talking about she was like
if if homeboy if homeboy gonna get in
these shoes like he's gonna get it
that's what she said if he's rolling up
in these shoes homeboy is gonna get it
all right cringe cringe but I also have
never really heard Amanda Seyfried speak
out of character like out of a role so
maybe that's just her personality
dude like [__] man like get the writers
it's literally so [__] funny like I
don't think I'll ever get over it it's
the best clip of all time she's so
passionate and she also has no [__]
idea what's going on
it's beautiful combination beautiful
combination it's a beautiful combination
yeah so sad for Jennifer Coolidge on SNL
but also why wasn't she on earlier this
season like her big moment of the year
like were kind of a few months ago I
feel like she could have been on sooner
and we could have avoided this and she
also could have been on when the last
white load is premiered so I just kind
of feel like SNL is kind of bandwagging
winning off of her success no no I
waited too long and they were too
stubborn and look look what happened
it's the one you got yeah this is their
fault right like when's White Lotus was
on she could have been on SNL when she
was doing like her like Emmy campaigning
she was all over she could have been on
then no they waited till like she's
already irrelevant now and it's not
irrelevant you know what I mean like
she's not on the name on everybody's
lips currently yeah who would you say is
the name on everybody's lips currently
like today question changes day to day
that's an amazing question
yeah let me think hold on
honestly it's like still everyone from
Ben or pimp rolls it's so crazy did you
see they were talking about Vanderpump
Rules on The View yesterday yet because
Jayla was on Jayla was on and Whoopi
Goldberg was like do you watch it and
Trump rolls
uh yeah in JLo I saw that she said like
if her if Ben did that to her like she
would walk out the door
well yeah I hope so yeah wow hot take
JLo
duh
um also this is so random but I was
watching these videos this morning I
have to start sending it to you but I
want to give it a shout out to somebody
who I've started following on Tick Tock
his username is heartthrobert
and he does these re-watch videos he's
watching seventh heaven and we used to
watch seventh heaven growing up and we
loved it and I guess we didn't realize
how absolutely [__] moronic it is
because they're trying to tackle these
like real life issues in like this
really old school like PC Christian
family Pastor kind of way so they're
trying to do this they're doing this
episode on like drug addiction but
they're not gonna do actual drugs in the
show you know this is a nice family so
the kids in the family two of them get
um into uh like herbal energy pills
so they're like up all night in the
courtyard playing basketball and then
like the girl that she's playing with
from her High School takes like a whole
handful of herbal energy pills and has a
heart attack and has to go to the
hospital and Jackie these videos are so
funny you forget how [__] moronic
they show us I will send them to you I
just I think everybody needs to go watch
these videos it's in his rewatch
playlist I was watching him this morning
with Ben tackling they did an episode on
gang violence there's this girl at the
high school who has a gun under her bed
like it's so stupid that's crazy and
then it's also crazier that the Father
the red brand is a pedophile in real
life yep so in his videos instead of
calling the dad the pastor he calls him
the pedophile it's so fine
that they're the best videos
that was crazy what's his name Stephen
like something is he in jail
I think so
that was Loki and like the show like
Jessica Biel is in the show like it's so
crazy Beverly Mitchell
Beverly Mitchell
good times that's crazy that Jessica
Biel is in the show though
I know that's like how we know her
that's how she is who she is 7th Heaven
yeah
wow
yeah well are you ready for our fifth
and final story
I am I'm ready to get get into it it's
little influencer Tick Tock drama that
I'm also going to need you to explain a
little bit because I'm not understanding
like the alleged crimes okay Beauty
brand tarte has apologized for a
miscommunication after a Tick-Tock
influencer claimed she was treated like
a second-tier person on a proposed brand
trip
so the beauty brand tarte has apologized
for a miscommunication that led a tick
tock Creator to feel slighted and pull
out of a brand trip slated for the hotly
anticipated Miami Grand Prix auto racing
event this weekend but what may have
started as a miscommunication has spun
into a heated dialogue about bias and
privilege Bria Jones is a lifestyle
influencer with 458 000 followers she
shared her frustrations in a viral tick
tock on Wednesday saying she felt she
was treated like a second-tier person
quote
Bria said quote I'll be damned as a
black Creator if I accept anything other
than equal treatment on these trips she
said that she did receive an invite to
Sunday's race but that it was rescinded
to due to a typo she also acknowledged
that her numbers are not like some of
these other creators assuming that was
the reason she was left out of Sunday's
Affairs but she said being excluded made
her feel less than because she was not
invited to watch the Formula One race on
Sunday after discovering her other
influencer friends would be attending
however she wound up deactivating her
account by Thursday telling Insider that
she had received online bullying and
death threats after tarte's CEO
responded to her video in the CEO's
video and then in a statement to Insider
from the CMO of the company the company
said that a miscommunication stemmed
from the fact that arrivals and
departures were staggered for all
creators the brand had invited to the
three-day event and that no creators
were given preferential treatment over
others amid some confusion in The Tick
Tock Community taking sides um
this is what we know about Let Me
Explain let me explain okay let me
explain thank you so tarte is doing
another influencer trip they just did
one in Turks and Caicos which is now
being brought into the conversation but
the conversation started about the
formula F1 thing in Miami so this girl
was basically like I'm was going I was
so excited and I was like talking to my
other influencer friends and this girl
who made the video Bria her flight she
was looking was like scheduled to leave
I don't know if this is the right day
but let's say like Saturday and the
fourth Thursday One race is Thursday
okay and the Formula One race is on
Friday it's like tart whatever sorry so
she was basically like brought on the
trip but she wasn't gonna stay till the
end and so they had basically had people
coming for different amounts of time and
I'm sure like the really famous or you
know lots of followers people were
getting to stay till the main event
um but not everyone you know they're
Limited in how many rooms they had and
whatever so they I'm sure they said they
weren't doing it on based on treatment
but I think they should just be honest
and say that they were because this is a
business like of course like if we want
content made on Sunday with the race we
want the girl with 10 million followers
like it's not crazy to say that
um and then everybody just started
having conversations like yeah well you
know they just did this whole week in
Turks and Caicos and they had like
shifts of people coming in and everybody
was doing room tours and it was like
well this person got a big Suite with a
slide and this person didn't only have
one window and now they're like they're
treating people you know based on their
followers and and ranking them and it's
like yeah is that bad
like it's it's a brand trip not a
charity trip like if I if I had a brand
and I was spending they probably spent a
[__] ton of money I want the people who
have the most to to offer me I'm gonna
offer them the most too right and you
want them to come so if you're if if you
want them to come to your formula one
weekend but they're not getting a ticket
to Formula One like they might those
bigger accounts might not come but the
smaller accounts might come because like
that that's enticing that might be the
only opportunity that they have where
it's like somebody with 11 million
followers if they want to go to F1 like
there's a million Brands that'll take
right it's the same thing as like you
know someone with more followers being
paid more for that weekend than someone
with less followers right because you're
just like being paid based on the
exposure so I think you've said that
like tarte doesn't necessarily pay their
influencers for these trips so the
accommodations and the perks are the
payment so the more your rate is
then the more perks that you would get
like that
nobody gets paid to go on these trips so
I don't know if we would be having this
conversation if people were mad that
somebody with 10 million followers got
paid 100 grand for the trip and somebody
with 500 000 followers got paid 10 grand
for the trip I think that I think the
accommodations I honestly well that's
but I understand that's not how the
world works I would disagree with that
I would too like accommodations in this
scenario are the form of payment so
length of your stay room type and I saw
Brianna chicken fry actually made a good
video about it because she was like I
got a [__] room and like I didn't care
one because it was just like we were
having fun and two because like I know
how many followers I have and I know
that like when you look at the people
who were there like some of them have
like 15 million followers like it is a
ranking system and I think it's okay to
say that because I don't think that's
necessarily bad it's the same way like
at any sort of job somebody with more
seniority and more skill or whatever
gets paid more it's it's a ranking
system that's that's the capitalist
world we live in and I don't know if
there's some necessarily anything wrong
with that no I I think there's nothing
wrong with it I think it's foolish to
think that it should be
a different way or like that and also at
the end of the day like all you girls
are going on a free [__] trip with
all these perks like staying at Prince's
old house on the beach like having the
time of your [__] life so your room
was smaller than someone else's like
tiny violence I'm sorry I don't care
yeah no I agree and I think there's a
difference and I didn't see her cite any
of this but like if if people from the
company were actually treating her
differently in like a personable way
like that's wrong like that is wrong but
that's not what I saw and maybe maybe I
didn't see more stuff but what I saw was
basically like valuing you know room
types and length of stays and you know
how much products you got in your room I
got three concealers she got two like
that I think is like Petty and again
these are unreal opportunities and I
honestly think tarte would be better off
being totally honest and being like yeah
of course like the person with 15
million followers is gonna get the sweet
on the top floor and the person with 200
000 followers and you know what's so
crazy is like in the grand scheme of
Tick Tock and this girl has 450 000
followers like that's really low
comparatively in the beauty space like
that's low it is yeah agreed also tart
when they were trying to like explain
their I think the the Turks and Caicos
trip like was clearly based on following
hierarchy rooms Etc but this F1 trip
um they tried to clarify the varying
schedules saying that every creator that
was invited was asked to come for a
three-day duration staggered throughout
the week so for some creators those
three days included the actual race for
other creators it was just like three
days leading up to Formula One in Miami
and they said the entire event was three
days and to spread the love we had
invited many creators to join us each
for one of the three days all creators
had an equal itinerary with one day at
the race one dinner and one nightclub
event and no one was staying longer than
anyone else she added that creators with
all different size followings were
invited across the three days right so
so if you don't want to rank based on
following then only the big creators
would be invited in the future like is
that better
no I don't think I don't think so
no I will say like in terms of makeup I
feel like for the last couple of years
tarte has kind of like fell to the back
burner they were really hot for a while
and then like all these other brands
popped off and I think people forgot
about chart but they've really been
doing a good job of like especially with
these trips and in you know Tick Tock
which is like the center of the beauty
space now it's not YouTube anymore
they're really killing it and I honestly
think conversations like they like this
are you know at the end of the day good
for the brand because we're talking
about tarte and and I also I really I
don't I haven't heard anything that I
feel like they did anything wrong
yeah no I and you know and by the way I
am sympathetic like it definitely sucks
to like be on a trip and like know that
like you're you know considered like
less valuable or or
less important because of followers
which is just like this abstract like I
get it like on a personal level like
that [__] sucks like I totally get it
but I don't think really like anyone who
was invited on the trip like really has
anything to complain about based on what
I've seen yeah
also the
the founder had made like a tick tock
video talking about how she was like sad
that Bria had felt this way and that
also
um
they didn't realize people would like be
upset about like what's going on on the
track like she said I wasn't thinking
what's going on in the truck I was just
thinking how we can get people to have
this most fabulous experience it's like
of course I don't know who the [__]
race would be so important to people
yeah and by the way like I'm sure
because like Tick Tock in general is
crazy the beauty Community is like so
like the fact that this girl had to
deactivate her account when she was just
like sharing her experience even though
maybe I don't necessarily agree with it
like that sucks and I'm sure she's like
bugging into having the worst week ever
yeah because it goes like you know the
mob just goes from here to there to here
to there so when she first post her
video they're all like yeah why isn't
everyone treated the same and then they
hear the response like and they're like
well why are you complaining that you
didn't get to stay one extra day on your
glamorous free trip and it's just it's
in it's impossible and then it just it's
so dark it gets so dark so I do feel bad
for this Creator if she's getting like
mean messages and it's nobody deserves
that it's impossible
it's impossible to win and while I don't
agree I think like everyone needs to
calm the [__] down
but like
it's just no at the end of the day like
tart tart is running a business this is
you know a business this is not like a
free-for-all charity like for them to be
intentional with room giveaways that to
me that's smart business sense if I was
running a brand trip and somebody who
had 15 million followers agreed to come
[__] take it out of my room they could
have my [__] room okay yeah also it
seems like the Turks and Caicos set up
and the Miami one were different in
terms of like what perks were given and
if anything sure because the Miami trip
might have been a little more Equitable
just because it was like three days for
everyone
um I'm sure they're saying like in
hotels and not like a house where
there's only like some rooms are bigger
there than other rooms they can't
rebuild the house they're not gonna
build a house that's like has equal
rooms right forever for the brand traps
for the brand trips
yeah but it's just an interesting
conversation that's being had on tick
tock
yeah I don't know
I don't know complaint talk is like one
of my least favorite Trends on tick tock
I don't disagree yeah
so that's what that's what you missed
on Glee and that's your final episode of
the week on Monday Jax and I are back in
studio I'll be back in New York make
sure to be following me on Instagram and
make sure to join the patreon because
we're gonna get some sickening content
and we're gonna make Vlogs and get ready
with me and I'm so excited and Jax I
miss you so much like it's not the same
even though I'm staying at this hotel
and I the one that you were supposed to
stay at and I know you would [__]
hate it here like I can just tell this
aesthetic is so not your Vibe like I I
walked in I'm like honestly it's like a
cool hotel you know so it's like loud
and there's like bar and drunk people oh
my God I got in the elevator last night
after Shannon sprayed me and I'm like
not wearing my shoes and I couldn't
figure out how to swipe the [__] key
like press my room number I hate that
[__] even though it's a good for
security so they take me up to the
Rooftop Bar even though I didn't press
anything and these like gaggle of like
drunk Elders got in they're literally
standing on my feet like love your shoes
where are they from screaming in my face
and I was like you know what blessed be
the Lord that Jackie's not here
uh yeah well I'm sure that you also came
like at night it's a big weekend in
Asheville there's all the grads like
maybe today will be a little exactly
more civilized
well we're gonna get this up episode
uploaded for you guys and then we're on
our way we'll be back on Monday Jax I
love you I love ya
thank you so much for listening to the
test and Monday Morning Show where we
deliver the fast five stories you need
to know everybody watching this on
YouTube please subscribing this video
thumbs up also available Spotify Channel
videos hope you guys have a great
weekend and we'll see you on Monday love
you bye